my name is Tanya Dwyer your host for the
next hour or so and I'm very happy to be
delighted - very happy to be delighted
to be honored to be smiling that rich
Vogel's here sir
Stallworth of the MMO world and you guys
are here with battle cry studios a very
different game - I think what people
would associate your rich tapestry of
games you've absolutely passionately so
you were obviously involved in the older
public and as far back as Ultima Online
Star Wars Galaxies as well battle cries
a very different type of game absolutely
explain for the folks at home I think
that CG trailer a lot of people have
seen what what's the sort of the the
what are the bones of a pile across so
basically what we did is we look for we
didn't want to do a MOBA we didn't want
to do an FPS we didn't want to do an
action RPG we looked around and said no
one's doing an action combat game and
multiplayer mode yeah
so we looked around and we took you know
we winrar we looked at arcane we looked
at Arkham Asylum we looked at Devil May
Cry we looked at God of War that's our
inspirations we said this is the game we
want to build with a close third person
camera and be able to put people into
the combat arena and so we said we
wanted to make our combat intimate and
personal so how do we do this well we
didn't we didn't want to have guns in
our game so we didn't want to make an
FPS so we came up with some backstory
fiction that a wool war happened 200
years ago and they banned gunpowder okay
and so they had treaties formed where
these battle zones or war zones we call
them players would come in these elite
warriors to come in and fight over
disputes so we have three facts in our
game two are announced at e3
it's the Cossacks with the Russian based
and the British Empire which is
obviously the English based faction and
we have one more that we haven't
announced yet and they'll be fighting
for these elite warriors we funding and
there are five classes that we have
they're very unique with unique
abilities that you level up over time
that goes into tearing and you can open
up new weapons and new abilities as you
go up the SU progress and there's a
metal war as well that gets people have
fight over the map and the cool thing
about our game is number one is we're
showing very basic team deathmatch here
but the reality is we're really about
co-op
so we're going to have other modes that
are very cooperating objective oriented
that players are used to so we want to
attract the FPS and multiplayer fans out
there and the kind of tagline we used is
this is a Team Fortress 2 meets the
brutality of 300 awesome that's what
we're about so we're looking at a
gameplay here of course this is being
led artistically by Victor octenol was a
somebody people were very familiar with
terms of half-life dishonored and I one
of my favorites kingpin life of crime he
was also involved in absolutely it looks
absolutely stunning oh yes so we really
wanted to make our art style stand out
and be very unique we kind of use it in
the sense of these places are weird
warriors are going to die so when you're
in that kind of situation you're in
battle
everything is surreal and so that's kind
of like what we did in our art style and
the other things you can see here we
have these magnetic poles that allow
players to move the map quickly we have
a lot of verticality in our maps and
this helps with number one gets our we
do have warriors in our game that are
range as well as melee so we want to
make sure that there's not this huge
clumping going on in our games and his
accident the ability for players to
cheat ejek Lee look at the map and
position themselves and again the
enforcer that you see here he's the tank
of our game he's the one the big sword
we have the duelist which the
double-edged that's the assassin and he
has a stealth ability that comes in and
he can go in and tack quickly and come
out we have really good female warriors
in our game we're not as scared to have
female warriors in our game we have them
in our game Brunson Center as well
absolutely their front Center the
cossack female enforcer she is amazing
she is brutal with her sword and someone
you won't don't want to miss now the
other thing you see his sword turned
into a shield and we have this thing
because again if gunpowder wasn't around
how would these weapons evolve over time
yeah so we have it called Pan soppec
technology that these weapons have a lot
of cool but the turn of this century
which is the Industrial Age this this
happens in 1915 on our alternate
timeline so that you can see the
lightning which is basically magnetic
way of doing things and you'll see
weapons transform into like the big
knife big sore
into a shield and then there's like
adrenaline that you earn in the game
that gives you some kind of super
abilities for a while so someone gangs
up on you if your arranged you had the
super ability that you can use to get
out of it
it's the games you're referencing at the
star that got a four and then then there
was our games that are often the combat
sort of works because you're fighting
other AI and they can be you know you
can take on groups it must be very
challenging to have player versus player
absolutely become but how do you get
around people feeling like they
understand where they're striking and
they don't feel helpless
yeah so one of the things that's what
our combat right hangout we're showing
pre-alpha combat right now but we were
gonna have a whole bunch of indicators
in the game they're more visceral you
see them being able to cut people apart
but we're gonna have like the killing
blows where the camera slows down and
you can see the killing blow happen and
and we'll have like people will know
when they hit when they strike they'll
know if the players about ready to go
down we'll have all that visceral stuff
like the blood on them but you don't see
here but we'll be in the game you know
you see metal hitting metal there'll be
a whole bunch of what we call visual
cues for the player again we want to
make it an action combat game that's
what we're about so we want to make sure
it's really intimate like that then it's
again that's what we're about and it's
really I think what what you see in this
free alpha is just the beginning of
where we're gonna head now as you see
here we're doing the kind of old-style
turn of the century type of leaderboards
where they show up the best of the best
and they do newspaper and the cool thing
about the end of the game is we want to
promote a healthy community so we allow
people at the end of a match to go
salute people and give them badges that
they actually can use to gain experience
in the game so there are their opponents
absolutely Wow okay so it's a good way
to promote community in our game in a
positive way because these games have a
bad way of promoting connect yeah so
we're trying to use that as a great game
mechanic so talk about the meta game a
bit then C's obviously there is the team
that matches the objective based stuff
but then outside of that is their wider
yourself larger war that you're fighting
with your faction so you get faction
points toward that and also territory so
you'll see a map that you'll be finding
a board they'll be updated in real time
we don't really want to talk too much
Beks we're still in development on that
but that is the metagame
that everyone we fighting for excellence
yes so team that matches is something to
people you know expect from these types
of multiple ways can you talk a little
bit about the objective based thought we
will have several objective based mode
so it'll be each one will have its
unique feel and difference and you know
we're even looking at even having mixing
up AI into that okay as well so it's
gonna be really cool this is just the
beginning of what we're starting right
now I think that people are playing with
we have it on the floor and people
really get into it easily and they
really enjoy playing the different
characters in a game a lot of people
love the female warrior in our game
she's very tough you know we took our
inspiration from lepen lakita and other
movies of inspirations yeah the woman
with the Dragon Tattoo and things like
that they're very tough warriors and you
don't want to mess with them awesome
battle cry at battlecry Studios is a
sort of it came out of nowhere of a
couple of months ago but as da viously
are having guys publish this game as
well and and the game as well and
considering the big names that are
working on it it was sort of like a nice
little surprise and how is it that you
guys already have an alpha version to
show here oh yeah we even have a great
team we have people from Halo
multiplayer from Call of Duty
multiplayer we have people from God of
War and Bioshock all working on our game
so we actually were very picking and our
hiring and very selective we have a very
small tight team working on this game
and we iterate we play our game twice a
week we iterate iterate iterate and
that's really our first our first few is
about getting the fun our second part is
about engagement yeah you know getting
players why would players want to
continue playing this game what makes
this game sticky that's what we're
working on right now is making sure we
have all the tearing going on all the
cool weapons designs that happen all the
cool modes that we're gonna have in the
game and the meta game well that's
obviously very important to you as
someone who's been involved in some of
the biggest mmo's absolutely assistance
and reason to come back and play that's
what that's what we're focusing on right
now we got the fun in now we're focusing
on on the engagement cool I've got a
bunch of questions that just want to get
from the folks who are watching at the
moment on GameSpot calm and what is your
inspiration for the art style Stewart
Hopkins oh definitely graphic novels
that we looked at we definitely looked
at the turn of the century and did a lot
of research on what the what the turn is
actually that's a very cool time period
right yeah you know it's a keen Art
Nouveau and Art Deco and a lot of really
cool architecture out to me was built
then so right now you see a very
European themed level because this is a
British back Jim yeah but the Cossacks
will be all in Russian and we take place
in Russia and it will be in its own
unique flavor and look for that so we
definitely used a lot of graphic novels
and comics as their inspiration for that
in fact our lead character artist
concept artist sorry is is the guy did
Pacific Rim oh really yes and he he did
all the weapons that you see here all
the transformations and things like that
he's amazing artist and he's a great
designer of just mechanical stuff and
it's amazing to see him work that's
incredible was his background in film or
was it absolutely it was in film so it's
just one of the first games he's worked
on absolutely and he's just he's just
incredible he just thinks out of the box
and the different weapons like this
that's the big huge sword transforming
into a shield I mean that's just him
just thinking of things like that and
you know you could see his background of
what he did and it's amazing it seems
like you guys have got that a real who's
who from all over the and our team works
really well over very tight team we're
keeping it small and tight and what
always happens when we have games like
this on that are competitive and and PC
is that folks are immediately asking
when can I have a go but myself so
obviously you guys are pretty early out
of the box is there gonna be betas at
some stage in the future when are you
looking for even release what are
actually so we're gonna be releasing PC
first but you know we have the
controllers on the floor yeah and it's
funny how people migrate more than the
controllers and the keyboard yeah but
yeah we have the controllers it's all
set up for for console if something will
we look seriously are going to be
looking at after the PC launch but yeah
right now we're gonna start beta in
early of 2015 okay cool so look for
signups in the fall yeah yeah where
should they go for for there'll be a
battlecry the game website you'll
actually google it under battle cry the
game you'll find it
and yeah so Dave Federman has any plans
for a console version of a Lacroix it's
not something that you're kind of
shopping around at the moment
no I mean this game cries to be on
console yeah because we got all our
inspiration from console games I mean
all of us our big console players and we
also are very big console designers so a
lot of our team have experience doing
console C you know it don't be surprised
if you see a camp soon and you're
working with Bethesda who are of one of
the you know PC stalwarts who are now
arguably have even been more successful
when they got onto consoles absolutely
so yeah we definitely see this game
playing well in the console a couple of
people asking about its specs probably a
bit early for that but specifications
for PC I'm assuming you guys are gonna
try and keep it as scaleable and open
absolutely we're using the Crytek engine
in our game and so it's pretty scalable
you know we've actually had you know
we're trying to look at 4k as well just
to see what that look like yeah the
scale that high it's but right now it's
it's pretty good it scales really good
for even people who have pcs today or
even two years back to play our game
excellence I'm right in saying as well
that this is free to play this is free
to play that's our business model yeah
we look at it but our first and foremost
is making fun and engaging and then
monetization on top of it but aren't we
really are careful about monetization
we're about play to win not paid I've
heard that a couple of times yeah
actually and yeah I guess in many ways
up you know some games there's a
negative association winners for perhaps
a lot of games and but I'm seeing it not
to be reductive I'm seeing a lot of Team
Fortress 2 in this which is very much a
game that people are used to just by so
we want to make sure one of our missions
of our studio is to take triple-a
qualities and put it free-to-play we see
a huge market there that's where we're
heading towards we believe there's not
many people in the hardcore free-to-play
and that's where we are so you're gonna
see all the triple-a values that you
normally see in games now free-to-play
do you have any idea what your micro
transaction model is going to be yeah
well we really are not quite yet to talk
about it again you know we look at look
at inspirations like League of Legends
and World of Tanks
cool
so you've been around a long time you've
worked on a lot of mmo's what's it like
working on a game like this was this
something you always wanted to do I
always wanted you I was a console person
way before I was an MMO person I worked
on console games for five years before I
even went into MMOs and I loved the
console in development and I loved PC
and basically you know we see definitely
where I'm heading this is a very tight
you know game that's not going to take
five years to develop and I think that's
one of the things that kind of burned me
out doing the MMO yes so long to develop
because they have so much content in
them and then once they're done it's a
continuing process you know you continue
on so basically we really wanted to do
something cool fast and we grow up with
today we're going to be very much
connected with the community as we go
forward so our website will be emerging
over the summer so you know get feedback
from our players figure out what will
people players like what they don't like
we're going to be very much involved in
and streaming to our players with twitch
and other mechanisms to get our players
involved in our game
excellent rich Vogel absolute pleasure
to meet you absolutely producer
battlecry Studios with battle cry we
can't to say can't wait to see more I
put the rest of development